-Guys, it is Tuesday. It is time
for "WeTweet." Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet ♪
♪ "WeTweet ♪
-Now, welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
Yep. You can vote for
all of them.
If you want to be nice,
you can just do that.
You can vote for none of them
if you don't feel like playing.
Whatever you want.
We're gonna see the results
live, though, right here.
And, Higgins,
you have your clicker?
Roots, got your clickers?
-Got it.
-Mm-hmm.
-Alright.
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
during the commercial break,
and then you can all like it
and WeTweet it.
-[ Laughs sarcastically ]
-Okay, here we go.
You guys ready?
Our first tweet is...
♪♪
-Wow! I guess not.
-It's like...
-I like to hold it open
for somebody who is far away
and then close it
right when they get there.
-Yeah, no.
Alright, let's see.
I think the votes are in.
Let's see the results
on this one.
I'm not feeling too...
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah.
Wow, right down the middle.
Some people
didn't even participate.
-Yeah, they didn't care.
-They didn't even
feel like playing the game.
-They didn't care for it so
much, they go, "I'm not voting."
-Yeah, I'm not voting.
I understand.
This next one says...
♪♪
-Come on.
-Yep.
That's getting some titters.
-That got titters.
-It got some titters out there,
some giggles.
People enjoyed it, I think.
-People nodding.
-Yeah. Let's see the results
on this one.
Wow! Same thing.
-"No thanks," they said.
-Yeah.
I'm not feeling too good
about these ones.
What was -- The first one was --
What was it?
-95.
-Oh, a 95.
-Then 103.
-This was 103?
-High fever.
[ Laughter ]
Dang!
-That got a bigger laugh
than the tweet.
-Yeah.
This one's going to be
good, right?
Alright.
-Let's see this next one here.
It says...
-Yeah!
That's more like "yeah."
It's not a laugh,
but like, "Yay!"
-Yeah.
-Like, they should.
-Well, it's got to
beat 103, right?
-Yeah, it's gotta beat 103.
-I think it'll beat 103.
I'm saying this one's
in the 130.
-130?
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna go 115.
-I'm with Tariq -- 115.
-Let's see. The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
-Whoa!
-141.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
-I was close to that one.
Alright. This one
is pretty good.
It says...
♪♪
-Yeah, this is going to be 180s.
-One of those big candles,
has like three wicks in it.
-Right.
"Here you go."
-It's like an inferno.
-And Glade --
-How much candle do you want?
How much candle can you handle?
Alright. Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, 171!
-There you go!
-I think that might be
the winner.
-Do you think they have, like,
"John Wick" candles?
-They should. They should make
"John Wick" candles.
-And there's four wicks.
Why don't you do that, man?
-I had -- You want me to do it?
-I think you should do it.
-With my money?
-Make some more money.
You know what I mean? Sell it.
-Yeah, sell the business?
-Yeah.
The wick business?
-I haven't bought a candle
in a long time.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Why not?
Because your house
does not stink?
-No, I just don't --
I don't really use candles.
-Really?
-Yeah. I like candles.
You know what it is?
We got those battery-powered
candles that are fake.
-Oh, the ones with
the thing that goes --
-Yeah. Safety first.
-Yeah, sure.
-I'm not a dangerous person
like you are.
You're like Evel Knievel
at your house.
-I am Evel Knievel.
-Lighting things on fire.
-I have 600 candles
around me at all times.
And next to it,
I have oily rags
and, like,
open gasoline containers.
I live on the edge.
-Yeah.
Listen to this last one here.
It says...
♪♪
You gotta do it.
You gotta do it right?
Right? You go, "Let's go.
Ready to come back?"
-Yeah!
-One more ride! Let's do it!
One more ride!
Alright,
let's see the results here.
No.
-Whoa!
-It is candle.
The winner is candle.
That is our winner right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Emma Thompson, everybody!